zach is with us in Maine hi Zach welcome
to the Dave Ramsey show I did how are
you better than I deserve what's up
so I'm graduating and getting married in
May yeah we might finance this was my
fiancee mm-hmm so we don't have any
credit card debt or anything but
combined we have three hundred and
eighty two thousand dollars in student
loan debt good lord
yeah and I'm graduating with my degree
in chemical engineering and I have a job
lined up what are you oh my gosh she has
one more year for pharmacy school and
what are you gonna be making about 70
really look engineering degree okay well
yes I'm in maintenance it's not super
high and I'm also working in a
manufacturing plant not using the
chemical engineering degree exactly oh
okay well the chemical engineering
degree is probably worth more than that
and it's something you need to consider
if you spend all this money to get a kid
on chemical engineering degree but uh so
you're gonna make 70 and she's gonna
make a hundred to one hundred and twenty
depending on where she works when she
gets out something like that so you like
200 and you're used to living on nothing
because you were both college yeah so
live on nothing and take two hundred
thousand a year and throw it at four
hundred thousand yeah like no life
that's nothing oh no it's not tough
you're used to living on nothing your
college freaking student you don't have
a life just continue to have no life get
out and I know you want to get out if
you went for $1,000 in that dude yeah
yeah yeah whoo you just realized that we
did something wrong and I mean it's it's
unfortunate that you know we give this
decision we want to get out we want to
do the right thing and we're gonna do it
and I'm just yeah having a hard time
seeing the light at the end of the
tunnel well the good news is is you do
have an analytical mind or you would not
have completed this degree and so you
have just not applied it to this subject
yet the subject of personal finance and
when you applied to this it's a fairly
primitive set of math
headaches it is how much can I pay on
the debt divided into 400 mm-hmm yeah so
a hundred is four years which is absurd
that you would spend a hundred thousand
dollars on lifestyle after you've been a
broke college student so I wouldn't take
four years okay I think you ought to be
out of debt in between two and three
years and have absolutely no life now
that's from the time that she gets out
passes her bars and becomes a pharmacist
yes and the good news is by the way as a
pharmacist you get the regular job and
then you work the weekends at the ER
because they'll pay her pharmacy
pharmacists rates to work weekends at
the ER and this is what you do when you
are broke people you work like crazy and
you are broke people dude that sounds
great that we can get out though you can
get out it's just going to be a painful
first two years of marriage and it's
gonna bind you together and you're gonna
have fought the dragon together and
you're gonna be you're going to be
locked in your relationship in a
beautiful wonderful way because of the
strain that you are going to impose on
yourselves otherwise you're gonna screw
around with this huge Mount Everest of
debt for a decade and mess up your life
don't do that yeah get after it man get
after it you can do that you'll get a
car later there'll be a car waiting on
the other side of this rainbow there'll
be a house waiting on the other side of
this rainbow there'll be a vacation
waiting on the other side of this
rainbow okay so you you guys got good
degrees that's the good news you didn't
get a degree and left-handed puppetry
right no you got marketable degrees
where you can both make six figures
fairly quickly early in your career and
so that's the only you know so the bad
news is you got a big hole the good news
is you're gonna have a really nice
shovel okay and I'll help you I'm gonna
give you a Financial Peace University
our nine week class and a one-year
membership I'm gonna pay for the whole
thing give it to you as a wedding gift
right now the two of you start taking
the class right now together
and let's start talking about this
because I'll tell you what you have a
strain coming upon your marriage you're
either going to have
strain of this debt or the strain of
paying off this debt that you two join
hands and choose to fight the dragon
together shoes will they choose choose
the string don't let it happen to you
don't be a victim of the strain so you
can do this man you hold on and will
Kelly I'll pick up we'll get you signed
up for Financial Peace University and
congratulations on your upcoming
marriage you can do this stuff do don't
be one of these people you see on TV
that they've lost their brain and they
act waiting on Bernie to clean up their
mess okay you go clean up your mess you
have a wonderful career in front of you
both of you use it build a wonderful
life and and that's what I want for you
so hey hold on again Kelly he'll pick up
and we'll get you guys signed up
moms and dads get Anthony O'Neill's book
debt-free degree show your kids how to
not do that you owe your kids that you
don't have to have any money
you just have to care about your kids
you can you can help your kids get
debt-free degree and show them how to
not do that wouldn't it be better if
they came out with both of those degrees
with no debt they could have done it
could have shown now but they're there
now and I can show them how to get out
of that too so we're gonna help you
wherever you are boys and girls that's
who we are